[Music]
the risk of getting covert 19 is
currently bigger than ever
because in winter we spend most of our
time indoors
where the virus spreads easily
covert 19 is a serious disease so far
there is no real cure
and globally more than a million people
have died
people of all ages are affected many
will suffer from long-term health
problems
and our lives and freedoms are a knock
down or heavily restricted
the way out of this crisis is
vaccination
vaccination will protect you and us all
it is also an act of solidarity if a
majority of us get the cover 19 vaccine
we can stop the pandemic the coven 19
vaccines developed and authorized in the
european union are safe
and effective they go through the most
rigorous scientific assessment
they are thoroughly tested by
independent laboratories and with tens
of thousands of volunteers to make sure
they are safe and effective vaccination
will help us get our normal lives back
gradually once enough people have been
vaccinated
we can start traveling partying
[Music]
we can be free again everyone who can
should get vaccinated
follow the advice from your public
health authorities and consult your
[Music]
doctor
you